I think that a lot of people felt like
there were some questions that weren't
answered or maybe that they they didn't
get to see the full story or know the
other characters perspectives on things
so I think that that's definitely
provided this year that Selena Gomez's
new song back to you on the thirteen
reasons why soundtrack ET sat down with
the cast ahead of the show season 2
premiere on Netflix tell me what it's
like to have Selena Gomez as an
executive producer what does she like on
sit or like what surprises you most
about Selena what's I remember what
surprised me the most about her is that
she's incredibly normal and I think you
build up these celebrities to be I don't
mean she's extraordinary but like
something of this no not not of this
world right you can't reach them they're
not actually yet but she's very
accessible and very open and honest and
she's very passionate about this story
and she's been involved with it since
day one so it's really cool to have
someone that has such a big platform who
really cares about mental illness or
mental health and you know have it being
a voice for that I would say the same
thing that she's incredibly in normal
when like when you meet yeah yeah we're
all just people but yeah we definitely
set different people and some different
light you know you think that they're
not like you essentially and she's just
like us so what surprised me was how
open she was about everything like she
the first day we met she we got really
deep about her what she wanted to do the
show and her personal relationship to it
so and that I think that's what
normalized her or says she goes through
the same things that we did she doesn't
always make things right
it's gonna keep happening I enjoyed last
season in this season this one is kind
of on the same thing that we are as sick
as our secrets knowing the fate of Alex
and knowing how things turned out with
Hanna how do you guys hope people
receive the other side of Hannah's story
I hope with an open mind and in a non
Jung non-judgmental way I hope people
after seeing the whole picture really do
form their own opinions and yeah and
have that inform how they make decisions
in their lives so it's just like they
see how we feel that we treated Hannah
how Hannah feels that versus how she
thinks she treated us
[Music]